Reader beware--
you're in for a scare.
My job is to scare people,
but in this master class,
I hope to teach you that writing
doesn't have to be scary.
When you start to write,
do a complete outline.
I start generally
with the ending.
If I know the ending, then
I can spend the whole book
fooling the reader.
I was a really fearful
kid, and I was always
sure something was
lurking in the garage.
Now, I can remember
that feeling of panic,
and I can bring it back and
try to put it into my books.
If you're writing for
kids, think about the age
of the audience constantly.
My big rule for writing
middle-grade harder
is that they have to
know it's a fantasy.
The real world can't interfere.
There's no divorce.
No guns.
No one ever dies.
Once you've
established that, you
can go pretty far
with the scares.
Writing for teens is
kind of the opposite.
It has to be very real.
They have to believe
this is happening.
I grew up in a very
wealthy suburb,
but my family was really poor.
I always felt like an outsider.
I was on the
sidelines observing,
and that's one
reason why I stayed
in my room writing so much.
That's the appeal
of writing anyway.
You're here creating
your own universe.
In this master
class, we're going
to talk about how
to go about getting
ideas, how I use twists, how
I come up with cliffhangers.
And I'm going to tell you how
never to get writer's block.
I will take you through
the whole process
and show you that
none of this is scary.
I'm R. L. Stein, and
this is my master class.